والزراعه السعوديه المهندس عبد الرحمن
الفضلي اتفاقيه شراء طائرات لصالح
البرنامج لاستمطار السحب حيث يهدف المشروع
الى بناء القدرات الداخليه ونقل وتوطين
المعرفه واستدامه الاعمال ورفع مستوى
تغطيه وكفاءه عمليات الاستمطار كما ان
المشروع يعمل على خط التكاليف المصاحبه
لتشغيل الطائرات من خلال توفير طائرات
خاصه
ومجهزه ايضا كذلك
بكافه تقنيات الاستمطار
المستهدفه اليوم هي المنطقه الوسطى الرياض
وحاير القصيم والمنطقه الجنوبي الغربيه
عسير والباحه ومرتفعات مكه المكرمه لكن مع
وجود الابحاث باذن الله تعالى سوف يكون
هناك
امتداد لهذه العمليات على مناطق استوجب او
تستدعي مننا عمليات استمطار صناعي لزياده
الهاطه للمطري في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الهدف اليوم الطائرات المملكه
لكل مناطق المملكه باذن الله تعالى متى ما
دعت الحاجه والدراسات الى اللي هي وجود
حاجه للاستمرار وايضا وجود جدوى للاستمرار
على هذه المناطق
معي هنا في الاستوديو المدير التنفيذي
للبرنامج الاقليمي للاستمرار في السعوديه
ايمن البارصي دائما حياك الله
من الرياض وخلينا نعرف اولا تفاصيل هذه
الاتفاقيه لشراء خمس طائرات لصالح وزاره
البيئه والمياه وكلها طبعا في اطار
استمرار صحيح تم الحمد لله توقيع اتفاقيه
شراء خمس طائرات تعتبر الاحدث على مستوى
العالم والمملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
هي اول دوله على مستوى العالم تتمتلك
الطراز الحديث من طائرات الاستمطار اربع
طائرات مخصصه لتنفيذ عمليات الاستمطار
وطائره مخصصه لعمليات الابحاث نستهدف من
خلال الاتفاقيه الى رفع الكفاءه التشغيليه
لعمليات الاستمطار بالاضافه الى نقل
وتوطين التقنيات في هذا المجال الطائر
الخامسه هي طائره ابحاث تتعلق بالاستمطار
صحيح مش دراسه المناخ بشكل كامل يعني صحيح
هذه الطائره مخصصه فيها احدث التقنيات
اليوم هي عباره عن مختبر على طائره يستهدف
جمع عينات مخصصه السحر بهدف دراستها ورفع
المستوى التشغيلي وكفاءه التشغيل العمليات
الاصليه اليوم انتم وصلتوا لمرحله
الثالثه تقريبا
على الرابعه وش ابرز النتائج اللي تحققت
من الاستمطار برنامج الاستمطار الحمد لله
اليوم احنا بعد ما اتمنى المرحله الثالثه
احنا نتكلم اليوم على تنفيذ 190 مهمه او
رحله استمراريه تجاوز
625 ساعه طيران التقديرات الاوليه للهاطل
المطري تتجاوز الثلاثه مليار متر مكعب على
المنطقتين سواء كان المنطقه الوسطى
والمنطقه الجنوبيه وبالتالي هذا
يعني هو هو هذا الرقم اساسي لنجاح هذه
التجارب اكيد اليوم احنا نستهدف بالاسنطار
الى زياده الهاطل المطري وبالتالي احنا
اليوم نعمل على تقييم التجربه بشكل عام كل
البيانات هذي راحتك تجميعها ومشاركتها
نجاح المراحل اليوم احنا في عمل مشترك ما
بين قطاع الابحاث والمراكز العالميه بحيث
انه نشاركهم المعلومات اللي اليوم احنا
تحصلنا عليها ومن خلالهم راح يتم تقييم
التجربه هذه ويعطون النساء لانه انا قريت
في في البحث عن هالبرنامج انه نسبه النجاح
وصلت 97% وهذا رقم كبير يعني احنا نتكلم
على الكفاءه التشغيليه فتنفيذ عمليات
الاستمرار مش البرنامج كامل يعني صحيح طيب
وين المناطق اللي ركزتوا عليها في المرحله
الثالثه تحديدا المرحله الثالثه كانت خاصه
بالمنطقه الوسطى لمنطقه الرياض والقصيم
وحايل وش النتائج اللي خرجتوا فيها جزء من
المجموعه الهاطل المطري كان مخصص للمنطقه
الوسطى ما شاء الله تبارك الله كان موسم
ناجح خلينا نقول والكفاءه التشغيليه
تجاوزت 97% خلال المرحله الثالثه وبالتالي
هذا هو ما دفعكم
او دفع الوزاره لهذا الاتفاقيه شراء
طائرات اكثر لان التجارب نجحت اكيد هذا
جزء منها ممتاز انتم كان عندكم 190 مهمه
كما ذكرت قبل قليل وين ركزت اغلبها المهام
تقريبا التوزيع نتكلم 30 الى 40% المنطقه
الوسطى والنسبه الاكبر للمنطقه الجنوبيه
بما انه كانت الفتره الاطول للمنطقه
الجنوبيه والمرحله الرابعه اليوم راح تكون
على المنطقه لاحظتوا في تغير في هالمناطق
الجنوبيه انا اتكلم على المناطق اللي تشهد
دائما هطول الامطار وبشكل يمكن لا ينقطع
خلال اشهر معينه من السنه لاحظتوا زياده
في كميات الامطار فيها صحيح من خلال شبكه
الرصد اللي يمتلكها المركز الوطني للارصاد
تم تسجيل جميع الكميات هذه الامطار واليوم
نحن في حيز عمل مقارنات خلينا نسميها على
خلال طوال الفترات بحيث انه تعطي معلومه
واضحه هل كان هذا بسبب خلينا نقول السجلات
الحاليه اليوم نتكلم عنه هو اختلاف موسمي
من موسم الاخر وهذا هو سؤال مهم وما يحصل
في المناخ والتغيرات اساسا اللي حاصله
فبالتالي
اللي يتابع يعني كميات الامطار في
هالمناطق زادت بشكل كبير حتى المره
الاخيره تقريبا من شهر في يتكلموا على
انها الابطال لم تحدث منذ عشرات السنين
صحيح فبالتالي لها علاقه بالبرنامج اليوم
البرنامج ياخذ جزء حيز من المعادله خلينا
نقول المناخيه باضافته للمواد هذه وتحفيز
السحب وزياده الهطل المطري بس يبقى السؤال
اليوم انه احنا في مراكز بحثيه متخصصه
لازم يكون
الملف البحثي متكامل بحيث انه نعطي جواب
شافي في هذا المجال ان شاء الله بالتوفيق
لكم ان شاء الله
مدير التنفيذي للبرنامج الاقليمي
للاستمرار في السعوديه سيد ايمن شكرا لك
شكرا
برنامج استمطار السحب
انهى ثلاث مراحل
ويستعد لاطلاق المرحله الرابعه
97% نسبه نجاح اعمال البرنامج
و190 مهمه استمطار حتى الان استخدام ثلاثه
الاف واربعمائه وخمس شعلات استمطار هطوله
ثلاثه مليارات وخمسمائه مليون متر مكعب
على المناطق المستهدفه